BILL: Here we are
in Overtime, uh...
-let's see.
-(APPLAUSE)
Oh, must have gone good tonight.
Uh. Louie,
do you have any suggestions
for keeping a family together
in this era
of hyper-partisan politics?
Well, yeah,
you kind of bridge the divide.
-You're a Mid-Western boy,
but you're a city slicker now.
-Yeah.
I think-- You know, like,
I visit home.
I go back to Minnesota
eight to ten times a year,
which is a lot,
but I work a lot there.
But I always see my brothers
and sisters, all the time,
and even the times
when we don't have time,
you gotta check in.
And I think it's about
checking in and keeping people
part of your life.
-And keep talking, right?
-Yeah.
Not cut people off, that--
Keep talking.
And even if you're mad at them,
or they're mad at you,
don't let them run away from you
and don't let them hide.
Okay. Geraldo,
after all the work--
(APPLAUSE)
...you did exposing
mental institutions,
like Willowbrook,
what do you really think
about Trump declaring we need
to reopen these institutions.
I think,
as Governor Spitzer knows,
there's a confusion
in the public mind,
between people
who are mentally ill,
which includes schizophrenia,
post- traumatic stress,
you know, uh... bi-polar...
That's different from my area,
which is the developmentally
disabled, mentally--
They used to call them
"mentally retarded."
Down syndrome, autistic, uh...
People who were warehoused
in institutions.
-BILL: Right.
-Not asylums,
but they were warehouses
that existed, people forget.
-Over five thousand people--
-The Kennedys put their...
(STUTTERS) And lobotomy,
and all the rest of it.
It was just horrible,
horrible treatment of--
One has, kinda normal IQ
and there's something off,
and those are the people
who are running down the street,
uh, with guns,
or things that look like guns.
And then the developmentally
disabled are people whose IQs
are below normal,
who you want to have as much
humane living environment
as possible.
They're gentle people,
they're obviously very needy,
but they can be...
you know...
(STUTTERS)
...take vocational training,
they can evolve,
they can live longer,
rather than be in institutions,
where 60 of them were jammed
in a room, naked,
smeared with their own feces,
unattended.
One attendant for 60 people.
I'll ask one more
Trump thing then,
when he did that thing...
-It was terrible.
-Okay.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
(BILL LAUGHS)
-HEATHER: Couldn't help it.
-Yeah, I couldn't help it.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Um... Max, do you believe
the US has learned
from our experience in Vietnam--
-Terrific book by the way.
-Thank you.
-Great book. Great writer.
I recommend it highly.
-LOUIE: Congratulations.
-(APPLAUSE)
-Uh...
Do you believe that the US
has learned from our experience
in Vietnam,
or that we are continuing to
make many of the same mistakes?
Obviously, not in Vietnam,
but I assume this person
means somewhere else.
Uh. Unfortunately, I think
we continue to make a lot
of the same mistakes,
and this is a frustration
for me, as a historian.
You can study the history,
you can draw the lessons.
Getting people to actually
internalize them and act on them
is something else.
And for example, today,
across the Middle East,
when we are fighting
the war on terrorism, I think
there is a tendency to think,
especially on the part
of the president,
that American bombs and bullets
will win the day.
And there was a similar tendency
in Vietnam to think
we could bomb the Viet Cong
into submission.
General William Westmoreland
thought we could kill
the Viet Cong faster
than they could be replaced.
And the guy that I wrote about,
Edward Lansdale said,
"No, this is never going
to work out,
the only way to win
is to have a viable instate,
a government in South Vietnam
that the people
can actually support.
And today, we're not really
focused on creating governments
that people can support
across the Middle East,
we're just focused on bombing
and then leaving,
and that's not gonna be
a successful long-term strategy.
Yeah, I know he talks about ISIS
being annihilated, but...
they may be annihilated
in Syria, but they're just going
to take their talents to...
LOUIE: South Beach.
-Well, that's what I was...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-But in their case,
Libya or Somalia...
-(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
No, that's what I was invoking.
-(BILL LAUGHS)
Remember what happened
with Al-Qaeda in Iraq.
Al-Qaeda in Iraq, which was
the predecessor of ISIS,
was annihilated by 2011.
Then President Obama pulled
our troops out of Iraq,
a decision I opposed.
As a result of that,
he created breathing space
for ISIS to arise
and to take this vast caliphate
across Syria and Iraq.
And my concern is that Trump
today, is going to repeat
that very same mistake,
that he and other Republicans
were criticizing
not so long ago.
-BILL: Do you think--
-LOUIE: Isn't it also true,
if I might say,
that we always look at our model
as the model
for other countries,
and we have no idea of all
these tribal things,
and all this history.
And I think we always try
to get these people
to do things our way,
and they don't have
what we have to do that.
They define freedom differently.
I mean, that was
George Bush's big mistake.
He was like,
"Everybody loves freedom!"
We also forget
that it's all about religion
in the Middle East.
We don't understand that
the Shiites are different
than the Sunnis.
We changed the order,
and the Iraq invasion of '03,
unsettled the society
that had settled,
however maybe unfair
it could be perceived from...
people in a democratic society.
But religion rules
in the Middle East.
It's been forever, a millennium.
It'll be forever.
And history that happened
600 years ago, to them,
is like yesterday.
Yeah.
That's not just the Middle East,
that's a lot of countries.
Yugoslavia,
when that place fell apart.
You've gotta have on-the-ground
understanding,
like the guy I wrote about,
Ed Lansdale,
who spent years
in the Philippines and Vietnam,
and really came to understand
the society.
And he was trying to talk
truth to power...
to generals who thought
they could just bomb
their way to victory.
But today, you know, I see,
unfortunately,
a similar mindset,
where, again, there's not--
In the White House,
you don't see a lot of people
who are very worried
about the dynamics
of tribal society in Iraq,
or Syria, you know.
Trump just wants to throw--
you know, bomb-- bomb them
and then think that
we're gonna win that way.
We have the phrase,
"wag the dog."
Other presidents have been
accused of starting wars
to distract,
do you think Trump
is above that?
ELIOT: No, I-- (STUTTERS)
MAX: There's almost nothing
that Trump is above,
I would say. (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-BILL: Oh... Geraldo!
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
BILL: I'll hold him,
you punch him.
When you say something
like that,
what you ignore is that
we get one president
at a time.
We get one president--
When he succeeds,
the nation succeeds,
when he fails,
the nation is failing--
-MAX: I'd love to see
him succeed--
-BILL: Yeah, so would I.
When you alienate yourself
from the government, and say,
"Nothing they do
is worth a shit,"
then the country--
BILL: But that's not
what we're doing.
(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
We're not saying we don't want
him to succeed,
what we're saying is that
his absence of fact-based
decision making.
-BILL: Right.
-And as Geraldo
just pointed out--
-(APPLAUSE)
-GERALDO: I'm Geraldo.
(CHUCKLES)
As Bill just pointed out,
the decision to move
the National Guard
to the border,
I view as a manifestation
of a bad week,
he wants to distract.
He does something--
Barack Obama did the same thing!
ELIOT: Yes. No, no, no,
but not in this moment, not--
George Bush did the same thing!
(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
We all-- We all want him
to succeed, this guy won't.
BILL: But, by the way--
GERALDO: When was the last time
you said something nice
about him?
-BILL: Ask me that. Ask me that.
-ELIOT: Earlier in the show.
Earlier in the show.
GERALDO:
Okay, when was the last time?
When he made the--
When Kim Jong-un said, uh,
"Let's meet,"
and Trump said,
"Great, let's meet."
-And all the liberals said,
"That's crazy"...
-Great.
...and I said, "No, you know,
these two guys probably
are the two craziest people
in the world, they might
understand each other."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-I also supported--
-...Laura Ingraham also.
I also supported moving
the capital to Jerusalem.
So, believe me, I am perfectly
capable of agreeing with him--
I'll give you another one.
Another one that's important,
the tariffs.
The Democrats should stand up
and say, "You know what,
it's time we stood up
against China.
We should do it
as a global coalition,
not as one-off deals."
Somebody had to stand up,
China was gaming the system.
Wait a second,
I don't think Democrats
ought to be supporting Trump's
trying to start a trade war
with China.
This is not going to
work out well.
No, but we need to stand up
to China on trade.
It's about time we did it.
Yeah, but not-- not this way.
Not this blunderbuss approach,
with these massive terms.
...but we need to stand up.
It's about time
somebody said that.
Eliot, what do you think about
Republicans deregulating
the banks?
And some Democrats
deregulating the banks?
Well, here's the thing I'll say:
It's been so many years since
we had a financial crisis,
-don't we want one?
-(HEATHER LAUGHS)
-(GERALDO LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-GERALDO: Ten years.
-It's the single-most
moronic policy move I've seen
since moving the National Guard
to the border. It is--
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
I mean, this is-- (LAUGHS)
The fact that ten years after
the crisis,
we want to go back
and recreate the very predicate
to the crisis of '08
just makes no sense.
Banks are lending,
they're lending enough.
The economy is booming.
Why go back to minimizing
and limiting the amount
of capital they need?
It's insane. Simply insane.
-But it's also--
-(APPLAUSE)
I completely agree with you.
One of my happiest moments
in Washington D.C.,
they are few,
was when I worked on
the Wall Street Reform Bill.
Sat there at the bill signing,
saw us really try
to turn the page,
from a time when Wall Street
and the banks wrote
all of the rules.
And the fact is, they still are
the biggest donor
to Democrats and Republicans
in the financial sector.
And seeing that list
of Democrats
that Elizabeth Warren
had the guts to call out,
that list of Democrats
who are saying, "You know what,
let's deregulate again.
-Let's go ahead and join
with the Republican caucus."
-BILL: Right.
This is why the Democratic Party
is not as popular
as it needs to be
with working and middle class
people of all races.
BILL: All right.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you, panel.
-(APPLAUSE)
-BILL: We did it again.